glenn greenwald has been thinking about
it a lot recently and he joins us
tonight so i that was the first thing i
me to say clearly i totally disapprove
of what the National Enquirer did to
Jeff Bezos I do but it does raise the
question what is Amazon doing to the
rest of us yeah I wish we were a society
that left consensual adult sex to the
people engaged in them and had no
interest in them and let that be between
them and their spouses or whoever is in
their personal lives but that's all the
reason why we should value privacy I
spent a lot of years as a journalist
defending that value and one of the
companies that poses the greatest threat
to it is Amazon it's a major source of
Jeff Bezos as wealth and power and you
know we think of Amazon through their
branding that it's a place we buy our
books from or download our Randall from
in fact their main business is working
with the security state agencies to
build huge apparatuses of the
surveillance state that invade our
privacy in ways far more severe than
what the national enquirer just did to
Jeff Bezos and that's a part of the
story that's so ironic beyond the fact
that Amazon is notorious for abusing its
workers something that all the people
that you just named would ordinarily
find quite upsetting that's so
interesting part of their business is
not selling toothpaste which is what I
use it for but but helping the national
security state gather information on
citizens right before you bought the
Washington Post Amazon had a 500 million
dollar contract with the CIA to provide
cloud services they are now using
artificial intelligence to build a
product called recognition that's
designed to use facial recognition
software to identify by the thousands so
wherever you go you can be identified by
software that the government is using
that Amazon is building they're using
security systems to around people's
perimeters of their houses and then
making it available to huge numbers of
people so they can see who's coming and
leaving your house who's inside of your
house the list goes on and on of the
products that Amazon is building and
profiting from way more than books that
are direct threats to our privacy
are critical components of the
surveillance state really quick what why
do I never read that story it's it's
because Silicon Valley is more powerful
in Washington than Wall Street is it's
because Silicon Valley now controls huge
parts of the media and the last thing
people in the media want to do is cover
Silicon Valley critically so the power
of Google and Facebook and so and and
Amazon is probably one of the most
important stories in the world and also
one of the most uncover under-covered
because of how powerful they are in the
media world going green well thank you
for that I appreciate it